[Musique]
le mobilier ccam avait procédé
télévision couleur en 1956 j'ai donc la
chance de se trouver une idée originale
ce qui n'arrive pas très fréquemment des
matches où cette idée originale de
qualité de vie du général souhaite c'est
de c'est qu'au lieu de s'acharner à
transmettre simultanément trois
formations ont pouvons transmettre deux
le principe de la télévision tout le
monde le connaît la caméra de prises de
vues de télévision classique permet la
transformation d'une image optique en un
signal électrique aisé à transmettre un
pinceau électronique décompose l'image
en ligne et sur chaque ligne mesure la
charge de chaque point d'image le signal
électrique ainsi formé peut être émis
par radio etc la télévision telle que
nous la connaissons
à la réception l'image se reconstituent
ainsi sur l'écran du téléviseur
point par point ligne parler et pour
reproduire des images en couleur
il faut que l'écran du téléviseur porte
des éléments phosphorescent coloré
frappé par un rayon électronique des
éléments s'illuminant leur couleur
caractéristique perdre ou double le tube
images comprend trois sources
d'électrons respectivement modulée par
des signaux électriques caractéristiques
de la composante verte rouge et bleu de
l'image a reproduit tous ces petits
points se fonde pour former une image
continue ce qui fait l'intérêt de
l'invention dans l'île de france et que
l'une des informations étaient mises en
permanence la luminance cependant que
les deux os ou chrominance sont émises
alternativement sans risque de mélange
dans le récepteur les informations de
chrominance suivent un double chemin un
chemin direct et un chemin avec un
dispositif à retardement
ce qui permet d'éviter ainsi toute
déformation de couleurs et comment vous
est venue l'idée
vous savez c'est extrêmement difficile à
dire parce qu on a d'abord une petite
idée
on expérimente et on modifie vu ça c'est
le point de départ lors on se dit bon
bah ça c'est une bonne voie
[Musique]